welcome to data analytics using python
my name is Richard kirschner with the
simply learned team that's
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead
so we're going to cover data analytics
with python we're going to go over what
is data analytics applications of data
analytics types of data analytics
data analytics process steps why python
for data analytics and then we'll dive
into use case demo so you can actually
see some script and actually see what it
looks like in the python code
what is data analytics
data analytics is a process of exploring
and analyzing large data sets to make
predictions and help data-driven
decision making now the definition of
large datasets keeps changing and so
this can range really from just about
anything to anything but usually in
today's world we're talking
significantly larger amounts of data
that you can't just glance at and try to
figure it out yourself and the two steps
are analyze the data and then make
decisions based on the data
applications of data analytics now the
sky's the limit on this in today's world
almost every business Act of Life your
music on your Spotify are driven by data
analytics but some of the big players
when you go in there job hunting are
going to be your fraud analysis if you
want to go make a lot of money and
you're good at it and you like dealing
with numbers go join the banks and track
down the criminals who are stealing
money it's a lot of you know it's a big
thing to protect credit cards predict
sales purchases bad checks any of those
things when you can track them down is
huge
Healthcare exploding there is everything
from trying to find cures for the covet
virus or any of the viruses out there
using your cell phone to diagnose
different ailments that way you don't
have to go and see the doctor you can
actually just go in there and take a
picture of the funky growth on your arm
hopefully it's not too big and then they
send it in there and the data analytics
goes in there looks at it and says oh
this is what this is this is a
professional you need to go see or don't
need to see
and that's just one aspect of healthcare
the database is being generated by
Healthcare and getting the right doctors
and helping the doctors analyze whether
something is benign or malignant if it's
cancerous all those things are now part
of the ongoing Health Care growth in
data analytics
Inventory management
think one of those huge warehouses where
they're shipping out all the goods how
do you inventory that in such a way so
that you maximize the stuff that's being
purchased the most near the entrance and
all the other stuff towards the back or
even pre-ship it so it's huge to be able
to inventory the manager inventory and
pretty soon they'll just have a drone
come in there and start picking up some
of those boxes and move them around also
deliver your Logistics again this goes
from getting from point A to point B you
can combine it with our inventory so you
pre-ship stuff if you know a certain
area is more likely to purchase it how
do you get it the delivery to the most
destinations the quickest in the short
amount of time and then they even
pre-stack the trucks going out and
that's all done with data analytics how
do we stack all that stuff so it comes
out in the right order
targeted marketing huge industry any
kind of marketing whether you're
generating the right content for the
marketing who are you targeting with
that marketing researching the people
what they want so you know what products
to Market out there all those things are
huge
and these are just a few examples you
can probably go Way Beyond this from
tracking forest fires
to astrology and studying the stars all
of this is part of data analytics now
and plays a huge role in all these
different areas
City Planning is another one you know
you can see a nice organized City like
this one where you can get in and out of
the neighborhoods if you're a fire truck
police officers need to be able to get
in and out you want your tourists to be
able to come in you still want the place
to look nice and you have the right
commercial development the right
Industrial Development like enough
residents for people to stay all those
things are part of your City Planning
again huge in data analytics
so sky's the limit on what you use it
for let's take a look at types of data
analytics
and this can be broken up in so many
ways but we're going to start with
looking at the most basic questions that
you're going to be asking in data
analytics and the first one is you want
descriptive analytics what has happened
hindsight how many sales per call ratio
coming out of the call center if we have
500 tourists in a forest and they have a
certain temperature how many fires were
started how many times did the police
have to show up to certain houses all
that's descriptive the next one is
predictive Predictive Analytics is what
will happen next we want to predict this
is great if you want to have a ice cream
store and you want to predict how many
people to work at the ice cream store in
a certain day based on the temperature
coming up in the time of the year
and then one of the biggest growing and
most important parts of the industry is
now prescriptive analytics and you can
think of that as combining the first two
we have descriptive and we have
predictive then you get
pre-scriptive Analytics
how can we make it happen foresight what
can we change to make this work better
in all the industries we looked at
before we can start asking questions
especially in City development there's a
good one
if we want to have our city generate
more income and we want that income to
be commercial based what kind of
commercial buildings do we need to build
in that area that are going to bring
people over do we need huge Warehouse
cells Costco sales buildings or do we
need little mom pod joints that are
going to bring in people from the
country to come shop there or do you
want an industrial setup what do you
need to bring that into industry in
there is our car industry available in
that area if it's not a car industry
what other Industries are in that area
all those things are prescriptive we're
guessing we're guessing what can we do
to fix it what can we do to fix crime
and area with education what kind of
education are we going to use to help
people understand what's going on so
that we lower the rate of crime and we
help our communities grow better that's
all prescriptive it's all guessing we
went foresight into how can we make it
happen how can we make this better
and we really can't not go into enough
detail on these three because a lot of
people stumble on this when they come in
and are doing analytics whether you're
the manager shareholder or the data
scientist coming in you really need to
understand the descriptive analytics
where you're studying the total units of
furniture sold and the profit that was
made in the past here we go into
Predictive Analytics predicting the
total units that would sell and the
profit we can expect in the future and
gear up for how many employees we need
how much money we're going to make and
prescriptive analytics finding ways to
improve the sales and the profit so we
can sell maybe a different kind of
furniture we're going to guess at what
the area is looking for and how that
marketing is going to change
data analytics process steps so let's
take a look at some of the basic
processing and what that looks like when
you're working with this data
so there's five basic steps the five
steps of processing and this changes and
then there's a lot of things that go on
when they talk about agile programming
the whole concept of agile is you take
some kind of framework like this and
then you build on it depending on what
your business needs
so the first step is data collection
and usually with a large company you
might have somebody who is responsible
for the database management you may have
another one where they're pulling apis
they're pulling data off of maybe the
Census Bureau maybe something very very
specific domain specific so if you're
analyzing cancerous growths and how to
understand them then the data collection
is going to be those measurements they
take from the MRI or it might be even
the MRI images they've used those also
so there's a lot of things with data
collection and how to control that and
make sure it has what you need and is
clean and you don't have misinformation
coming in
once you have the data collected there's
a data preparation
so stage two is we take that data and we
format it into something we can use
probably one of the biggest formats that
you see is when you're processing text
how do you process text well you use
what they call a one hot encoder and
each word is represented by a yes no
kind of setup so it'd be like a long
array of bits that's one way to prepare
it and so you know bit number one is the
bit number two is has or whatever it is
other preparations might be if you're
using neural networks you might be
taking integers or float numbers and
converting them to a value between 0 and
1. that way you don't have one of them
creating a bias in there so there's a
lot of different things that go into
Data preparation that is 80 percent of
data science so when we talk about the
data analytics which is a little bit
more on the math side and they usually
talk about a data scientist kind of
being the overall
prepare this stuff you're going to spend
80 percent of your data preparation
data exploration that's the fun part
this is where you're exploring things
and it is maybe 10 to 15 percent of what
you do with the data you spend with the
data exploration it is probably the most
important step because this is where you
got to start asking questions if you ask
your questions wrong you're going to get
some wrong information if you're working
with a company and they want to know the
marketing values then you really got to
focus on hey how do we generate money
for this company or fraud how do we
lower the fraud rate while still
generating a profit for data modeling
this is where we start actually getting
into the data code which model to use
that predicts what's going to happen
uh and then result interpretation we
want to be able to interpret those
results usually see that in your matplot
library where you create nice beautiful
images so it shows up on their dashboard
for the marketing manager or for the CEO
so they can take a quick look and say
hey I can see what's going on there you
want to reduce it to something they can
easily read they don't want to hear the
scientific terms they want to see
something they can use and we'll talk
about that a little bit more when we
start looking at some of this in a demo
since this is data analysis with python
we've got to ask the question why python
for data analytics I mean there's C plus
plus there's Java there's dot net from
Microsoft why do people go to python for
it
so the number of reasons one it's easy
to learn with simple syntax
you don't have a very high type set like
you do in Java and other coding so it
allows you to kind of be a little lazy
in your programming that doesn't mean
that it can't be set that way and that
you don't have to be careful it just
makes means you can spin up a code much
quicker in Python the same amount of
code to do something in Python A lot of
times is one two or three or four lines
where when I did the same thing say in
Java I found myself a 10 12 13 20 lines
depending on what it was
it's very scalable and flexible so
there's our flexibility because you can
do a lot with it and you can easily
scale it up you can go from something on
your machine to using a pi spark under
the spark environment and spread that
across hundreds if not thousands of
servers across terabytes of data or
petabytes of data so it's very scalable
there's a huge collection of libraries
this one's always interesting because
Java has a huge collection of libraries
C has a huge collection of
libraries.net does and they're always in
competition to get those libraries out
Scala for your spark all those have huge
collection libraries this is always
changing but because Python's open
source you almost always have easy to
access libraries that anybody can use
you don't have to go check your
licensing and have special licensing
like you do in some packages
graphics and visualization they have a
really powerful package for that so it
makes it easy to create nice displays
for people to read
and community support because python is
open source it has a huge community that
supports it you can do a quick Google
and probably find a solution for almost
anything you're working on
python libraries let's bring it together
we have data analytics and we have
python so when we're talking data
analytics we're talking python libraries
for data analytics and the big five
players are numpy pandas matplot Library
scipy which is going to be in the
background so we're not going to talk
too much about the scientific formulas
inside pi and PSY kit
so numpy supports in dimensional arrays
provides numerical Computing tools
useful for linear algebra and Fourier
transform
and you can think of this as just a grid
of numbers and you can even have a grid
inside a grid or data it's not even
numbers because you can also put words
and characters and just about anything
into that array but you can think of a
grid and then you can have a grid inside
a grid and you end up with a nice
three-dimensional array if you want to
talk three-dimensional array you can
think of images you have your three
channels of color four if you have an
alpha and then you have your X Y
coordinates for the image we're looking
at so you can go x y and then what are
the three channels to generate that
color
and numpy isn't restricted to three
dimensions you could imagine uh watching
a movie well now you have your movie
clips and they each have their X number
of frames and each of those frames have
X number of X Y coordinates for the
pictures in each frame and then you have
your three dimensions for the colors so
numpy is just a great way to work within
dimensional arrays
now closely with numpy is pandas useful
for handling missing data perform
mathematical operations provides
functions to manipulate data
pandas is becoming huge because it is
basically a data frame and if you're
working with big data and you're working
in spark or any of the other major
packages out there you realize that the
data frame is very Central to a lot of
that and you can look at it as a Excel
spreadsheet you have your columns you
have your rows or indexes and you can do
all kinds of different manipulations of
the data within including filling in
missing data which is a big thing when
you're dealing with large pools or lakes
of data where they might be collected
differently from different locations
and matplot Library
we did kick over the sci Pi which is a
lot of mathematical computations which
usually runs in the background of the
for of numpy and pandas although you do
use them they're useful for a lot of
other things in there but the matplot
library that's the final part that's
what you want to show people and this is
your plotting library in Python several
toolkits extend matplot Library
functionality there's like a hundred
different toolkits to extend matplot
Library which range from how to properly
display star constellations from
astronomy there's a very specific one
built just for that all the way to some
very generic ones we'll actually add
Seaborn in when we do the labs in a
minute several tool kits extend matplot
Library functionality and it creates
interactive visualization so there's all
kinds of cool things you can do as far
as just displaying graphs and there's
even some that you can create
interactive graphs we won't do the
interactive graphs but you'll see you'll
get a pretty good grasp of some of the
different things you can do in matplot
library
let's jump over to the demo which is my
favorite roll up our sleeves get our
hands in on what we're doing now there's
a lot of options when we're dealing with
python you can use pie charm as a really
popular one
uh and you'll see this all over the
place so it's one of the main ones
that's out there and there's a lot of
other ones I used to use netbeans which
is kind of lost favor I don't even have
it installed on my new computer
but the most popular one right now for
data science Now pycharm is really
popular for python General development
for data science we usually go to
Jupiter notebook or anaconda and we're
going to jump into Anaconda because
that's my favorite one to go to because
it has a lot of external tools for us
we're not going to dig into those but we
will pop in there so you can see what it
looks like so with Anaconda we have our
Jupiter lab we have our notebook these
are identical Jupiter lab is an upgrade
to the notebooks with multiple tabs
that's all it is and we'll be using the
notebook and you can see that pycharm is
so popular with python that we even have
it highlighted here in Anaconda as part
of the setup
Jupiter notebook can also be a
standalone so we're actually going to be
running Jupiter notebook and then you
have your different environments I have
we're going to be under main Pi 36
there's a root one and I usually label
it Pi 36
the reason is is currently as they're
writing this tensorflow only works in 3
6 and not in three seven or three eight
for doing neural networks but you can
actually have multiple environments
which is nice they're they separate the
kernel so it helps protect your computer
when you're doing development and this
is just a great way to do a display or a
demo especially if you're looking for
that job pull up your laptop open it up
or if you're doing a meeting get a
broadcast up to the big screen so that
the CEO can see what you're looking at
and when we launched the notebook it
actually opens up a file browser in
whatever web browser you have this
happens to be Chrome and then you can
just go under new there's a lot of
different options depending what you
have installed Python 3 and this just
creates an Untitled version of this and
you can see here I'm actually in a
simply learn folder for other work I've
done for simply learn
and that's where I save all my stuff and
I can browse through other folders
making it really easy to jump from one
project to another
and under here we'll go ahead and change
the name of this and we'll go ahead and
rename it
data analytics data analytics just so I
can remember what I was doing
which is probably about 50 of the
folders in here right or files in here
right now uh so let's go ahead and jump
in there and take a look at some of
these different tools that we were
looking at
and as we go through the demo let's
start with the numpy uh the least
visually exciting and I'm going to zoom
in here so you can see what we're doing
and the first thing we want to do is
import numpy
and we'll import it as NP that is the
most common numpy terminology
and let's go ahead and change the view
so we also have the line numbers I don't
know why we probably won't need them but
I'm looking for easy reference and then
we'll create a one dimensional array
we'll just call this array one
and it equals NP dot array and you put
your array information in here
in this case we'll spell it out you can
actually do like a range in other ways
there's lots of ways to generate these
arrays but we'll just do one two three
so three integers
and if we print
our array one
we can go ahead and run this
and you can see right here it prints one
two three you can see why this is a
really nice interface to show other
people what you're doing with the
Jupiter notebook
so this is the basic we've created an
array this is a one-dimensional array
and then an array is one two three one
of the nice things about the Jupiter
notebook is whatever ran in this first
setup
is still running it's still in the
kernel so it still has the numpy
imported as in p and it still has our
variable
arr1 for array 1 equal to NP array of
one two three
so we go to the next cell
we can check the type of the array we're
just going to print
we say hey what's what what is this
setup in here and we want type
and then we want what is the type of
array one let's go ahead and run that
and it says class numpy ND array so it's
its own class that's all we're doing is
checking to see what that class is
and if you look at the array class
probably the biggest thing you do I
don't know how many times I find myself
doing this because I forget what I'm
working on and I forget I'm working with
a three-dimensional or four-dimensional
array and I have to reformat somehow so
it works with whatever other things I
have and so we do the array shape the
ray shape is just three because it has
three members and it's a one-dimensional
array that's all that is
and with the numpy array we can easily
access stick with the print statement
if you actually put a variable in
Jupiter notebook and it's the last one
in the cell
it will the same as a print statement so
if I do this where array one of two it's
the same as doing print
array of two that's those are identical
statements in our jupyter notebook
we'll go and stick with the print on
this one
and it's three so there's our print
space two and we have 0 1 2
equals three we can easily change that
so we have array one of place two
equals five
and then if we print our array one
you can see right down here when it
comes out it's one two and five
and there I left the print statement off
because it's the last variable in the
list it'll always print the variable if
you just put it in like that
that's a Jupiter notebook thing don't do
that in pie charm I've forgotten before
doing a demo
and we talked about multiple Dimensions
so we'll do an array two-dimensional
array
and this is again a numpy array
and in the numpy array
we need our first Dimension we'll do one
two three
and our
second dimension uh three four five and
you can see right here that when we hit
the uh
we'll do this we'll just do array two
and we can run that and there's our
array two one two three three four five
we can also do array two
of 1
and then we can do let's do a zero it
doesn't really matter which one actually
just do two there we go and if I run
this it'll print out five because here
we are this is zero zero one two three
is under zero Row three four five is on
our one row now we start with zero and
then the two zero one two goes to the
five
and then maybe we forgot what we were
working with so we'll go do array two
dot shape
and if we do array two of shape
uh we'll go and run that we'll see we
have two rows and each row has three
elements a two-dimensional array two
three if you looked up here when we did
it before it just had three comma
nothing when you have a single entity it
always saves it as a tuple with a blank
space
but you can see right here we have two
comma three
and if you remember from up here we just
did this array 2 of oh let's go what is
it one
comma two
let me run that we get the five you can
also count backwards this is kind of fun
and you'll see I just kind of Switched
something on you because you can also do
one comma two to get to the same spot
now two is the last one zero one two
it's the last one in there we can count
backwards and do minus one and if we run
this we get the same answer whether we
count it as uh let's go back up here
whether we count this as 0 1 2
or we count backwards as minus one minus
two minus three and you can see that if
I change this minus one to a minus two
and run that
I get 4 which is going backwards minus 1
minus two so there's a lot of different
ways to reference what we're working on
inside the numpy array
it's really a cool tool it's got a lot
of things you can do with it
and we talked about the fact that it can
also hold things that are not values and
we'll call this array s for Strings
equals NP dot array
and put our setup in there brackets and
let's go
China
um
India
USA
Mexico doesn't matter we can make
whatever we want on here and if we print
that out
we run this you can see that we get our
numpy of Ray China India USA Mexico it
even gives us our D type of a U6
a lot of times when you're messing with
data we'll call this array R for range
just to kind of keep it uniform NP dot a
range
so this is a command inside numpy to
create a range of numbers
and if you're testing data Maybe you
want maybe you have equal time
increments that are spaced a certain
point apart but in this case we're just
going to do integers
and we're going to do a setup from 0 20
skipping every other one
and it'll print it out and see what that
looks like
and you can see here we have 0 2 4 6 8
10 12 14 16 18 like you expected it
skips every one
and just a quick note
there's no 20 on here uh why well this
starts at zero and counts up to 20. so
if you're used to another language where
explicitly says less than or less than
equal to 20 like for x equals zero X
plus plus X is less than 20. that's what
this is it just assumes X is less than
20 on here
if we want to create a very uniform uh
set you know zero two four six what
happens if I want to create numbers uh
from 0 to 10 but I need 20 increments in
there we can do that with line space so
we can create
um an R we'll call this l
equals I don't think we'll actually use
any of this again so I don't know why
I'm creating unique identifiers for it
but we'll do NP
Lin space
and we're going to do zero
to 10 or 0 to 9. remember it doesn't it
goes up to 10. and then we want to let's
say we have 20
different
um
increments in there so we're creating a
we have a data set and we know it's over
a certain time period and we need to
divide that time period by 20 and it
happens to just have 10 pieces in it and
here we go you can see right here we
have 20 or has 20 pieces in it but it's
over 10 years we got to divide it in the
middle and you can see it does it goes
0.52 remember yeah there's our 10 on the
end so it goes up to 10.
uh and then we can also do random
there's NP dot random if you're doing
neural networks usually you start it by
seeding it with random numbers
and we'll just do NP dot random and
we'll just call this array
we'll stop giving it unique numbers
we'll print that one out and run it
and you can see we have random numbers
they are zero to one so you'll see that
all these numbers are under one and you
can easily alter that by multiplying
them out or something like that if you
want to do like zero to a hundred you
can also round them up if it's integer 0
to 100 there's all kinds of things you
can do but generates a random float
between zero and one
and you have a couple options you could
reshape that or you can just generate
them in whatever shape you want and so
we can see here we did three and four
and so you can see three rows by four
variables
same thing as doing a reshape of 12
variables to three and four
and if you're going to do that you might
need an empty data set I have had this
come up many times
where I need to start off with zero and
I don't know you know because I'm going
to be adding stuff in there or it might
be 0 and 1 or 1 is if you're removing
the background of an image you might
want the background is zero and then you
figure out where the image is and you
set all those boxes to one and you
create a mask so creating masks over
images is really big and doing that with
a numpy array of zero
and we can also uh
give it a space
and we'll just do this all in one shot
this time
and we'll do the same thing like we did
before
zeros and in this case we'll do a two
comma three
and so when we run this
I forgot the asterisks around it I knew
I was forgetting something there we go
so when we run this you can see here we
have our 10 zeros in a row and maybe
this is a mask for an image and so it
has uh two rows of three digits in it so
it's a very small image a little tiny
pixel
and maybe you're looking to do something
the opposite way instead of creating a
mask of zeros and filling in with ones
maybe you want to create a mask of ones
and fill them in with zeros and we'll
just do just like we did before with the
three comma four and when we run this
you'll see it's all ones and we could
even do this even we'll do it this way
let's do
10.
10 by 10 icon and then you have your
three colors and you can so creates
quite a large array there for doing
pictures and stuff like that when you
add that third dimension in
if we take that off it's a little bit
easier to see
we'll do 10 again
and you can easily see how we have 10
rows of 10 ones
you can also do something like create an
array
and we'll do 0 1 2.
and then in this array we actually print
it right out we want a repeat and so you
can actually do a repeat of the array
and maybe you need this array
um let's repeat it three times
so there's our repeat of an array repeat
three times
and if we run this
you'll see we have zero zero zero one
one two two two
and whenever I think of a repeat I don't
really think of repeating being the
first digit three times the second digit
I really always think of it as zero one
two zero one two zero one two it catches
me every time but the actual code for
that one is going to be tile and again
if we do arrange three
and we run this you can see how you can
generate one zero one two zero one two
zero one two
and if you're dealing with an identity
Matrix we can do that also if you're big
on you're doing your matrixes and we'll
just identity
I guess we'll go ahead and spell it out
today any tricks
and the command we're looking for is
um
i e y e and we'll do three and then
we'll just go ahead and print this out
there we go there's our identity Matrix
and it comes out by a three by three
array because there's our Matrix
and then it puts the ones down the
middle and for doing your different
Matrix math
and we can manipulate that a little bit
too
we talk about
Matrix is
we might not want ones across the middle
in which case we now have the diagonal
so we can do an NP dot diagonal
and we do a diagonal let's put in the
diagonal
one two three four five and when we run
this
again this generates a value and by just
putting that value in there's the same
as putting print around it or putting
array equals and then print array and
you can see it generates a diagonal one
two three four five and there's your
your beginning of your Matrix array for
working with matrixes
and we can actually go in reverse let's
create an array equals remember our
random
random.random and we'll do a five by
five array oops there we go
five five
and just so you can see what that looks
like
helps if I don't mistype the numbers
which in this case I just need to take
out the brackets and there you go you
have your your five by five array set up
in there and we can know because we're
working with Matrix is we might want to
do this in reverse and extract the
diagonals which would be the 0.79 the
0.678 and so on
and we simply type in
NP dot diagonal
and we put our array in there
and this will of course print it out
because it returns it as a variable and
you can see here here's our diagonal
going across from our Matrix
and we did talk about shape earlier if
you remember you can do print the shape
out you can also do the dimensions so in
Dimensions very similar to shape it
comes out and just has two Dimensions we
can also look at the size so if we do a
size on here we can run that and you can
see as a size of 25 two dimensions and
of course five by five and that was from
the shape from earlier that we looked at
there's our five by five shape
and if you remember earlier we did
random well you can also do uh random I
talked a little bit about manipulating 0
to 1 and how you can get different
answers you can also do straight for the
integer part and we'll do minus 10.
and so we're going to Generate random
integers between minus 10 to 10 we're
going to generate four of those that's
when we run that we have 7 minus 3 minus
six minus three they're all be between
minus 10 and 10 and there's four of them
and now we jump into some of the
functionality of arrays which is really
great because this is where they come in
here's the array and you can add 10 to
it and if I run this there it takes my
original array from up here
with the integers and adds 10 to all of
those values so now we have oh this is
the decimal that's right this is a
random decimal I had stored in Array
but this takes a random decimal the
random numbers I had from 0 to 1 and
adds 10 to them and we can just as
easily do uh
minus 10
. we could even do
times 2
and we could do divide by two
and it would it'll take that random
number we generated and cut it in half
so now all these numbers are under 0.5
another way you can
change the numbers to what you need on
there
and as you dig deeper into numpy we can
also do exponential so as an exponential
function which would generate some
interesting numbers off of the random
so we're taking them to the power I
don't even remember what the original
numbers in the array were because we did
the random numbers up there here's our
original numbers and if you build an
exponential on there this is where you
get e to the X on this and just like you
can do e to the X you can also do the
log so if we're doing logarithmic
functions
that reinforced learning you might be
doing some kind of log setup on there
and you can see the logarithmic of these
different array numbers
and if you're working with a log base 2
you can do you can just change it in
there in P log 2. you have to look it up
because this is not log one two three
four five it is Log and log 2. so just a
quick note that's not a variable going
in that is an actual command there's a
number of them in there and you'll have
to go look and see what the
documentation is but you can also do log
10. so here's log value 10.
some other really cool functions you can
do with this is your sign
so we can take a sine value of all of
our different values in there
and if you have sine you of course have
cosine
we can run that
so here's the cosine of those and if
you're doing activations in your numpy
array and you're doing a tangent
activation there's your tangent for that
and the tangent activation is actually
from neural networks that's one of the
ways you can activate it because it
forms a nice curve between from whether
you're generating 1 to negative one with
some discrepancy in the middle
just jumping a little bit in there into
neural networks
and then we get into let me just put the
array back out there so we can see it
when we're doing this
as we're getting into this you can also
sum the values so we have NP sum
and you can do a summation of all the
values in this array and you'll see that
if you added all these together they'd
equal
12.519 and so on I don't know what the
whole setup is in there
but you can see right here the the
summation of this one of the things you
can also do is by axes so we could do
axes equals zero
and if we run the summation of the axes
equals zero
and you can think of that in numpy as
the rows so that would be or
you can think of that in numpy as being
the columns we're summing these columns
going across
and you can also change this to one
and now we're summing the rows
and so that is the summation of this row
and so forth and so forth going down
and maybe you don't need to um
know the summation maybe what you're
looking for is the minimum
so here's our minimal now you're looking
for and this comes up a lot because you
have like your errors we want to find
the minimal error inside of this array
and just like the other one we can do
axes equals zero
and you can see here
0.0645 is the smallest number in this
First Column is 0.0645 and so on
and if you have a minimum well you might
also want to know the max maybe we're
looking for the maximum profit and here
we go you can see maximum 0.79 is a
maximum on this first column and just
like we did before you can change this
to a 1 on axes you can take the axes out
of here and just find the max value for
the whole array and the max value in
here was 0.8344 so on so on
and since we're talking data analytics
we want to go ahead and look at the mean
pretty much the same as the average this
is the mean across the whole thing and
just like we did before we could also do
axes equals zero
and then you'll see this is the mean of
this axis and so on
and we have mean we might want to know
the median
and there's our median our most common
numbers if we have median we might want
to know the standard deviation or if we
have the average a lot of times you do
the means in the standard deviation
we can run that and there's our standard
deviations along the axes we can also do
it across the whole array
if we're going to do standard deviations
there's also variance
which is your VAR
and there's our variance across the
different levels
and so if we looked at that we looked at
variance we looked at standard deviation
the median and the means there's more
but those are the most common ones used
with data analytics and then going
through your data and figuring out what
you're going to present to the
shareholders
and some other things we can do is we
can actually take slices you'll hear
that terminology and a slice might be
like we have a five by five array but
maybe we don't want the whole array
maybe we want from one on we don't want
the zero in there so we got up to four
and maybe on the second part we just
want
two to row three and see this notation
right here says 1 to the end and if we
run this you can see how that generates
a single row to the end and then row two
and three now remember it doesn't
include three that's why we only get the
one column so if you wanted two and
three you would need to go ahead and go
two to four so it goes up to four
we could also do this in reverse
just like we learned earlier we can go
minus one whoops
and when we go to -1
it's the same thing because we have 0 1
2 3 4 this is the same thing as two to
four it goes two to the last one
also very common with arrays is you're
going to want to sort them so we still
have our array up here that we randomly
generated and we might want to um
sort it and we'll go and throw an axis
back in there
axis equals one if we run this
you can see from the axis that it sorts
it
the point two being the lowest value to
the highest value by the row we can also
change this of course to axis zero if
you're sorting it by columns so maybe
your values are based on columns
and then of course you can do the whole
array
and we can sort that I don't usually do
that but you know I guess sometimes you
might come up
and so you can see right here we have a
nice sorted array
something now let's just go ahead and
reprint our array so we can look at it
again starting to get too many boxes up
there something else you can do with an
array
is we can take and transpose it
this comes up more than you would think
when you transpose it you'll see that
the rows and the column are transposed
so where
0.79.57 0.064 is a column now we've
switched it and we have
0.79.42 as the index
you can see this really more dramatic if
we take a slice
and we'll just do a slice of the first
couple
and then we'll just do all the other the
full rows and if we run this you can see
how it comes up a little bit different
and we'll just do the same slice up here
so you can see how those two look next
to each other
there we go there's our slice run
and so you can see the slice comes up
and it has a one two three four five
columns now we have one two three four
five rows and three columns versus three
rows
and the original version when they first
started putting this together was a
function so the original version was
transpose and this still works you can
still see it generates the same value as
just a capital T
so many times we flip this data because
we'll have an XY value or we'll have an
image or something like that and it's
being read one way into the next process
and the next one needs it the opposite
so this actually happens a lot you need
to know how to transpose the data really
quick
and we can go ahead oh let's just take
um here's our transpose we'll just stick
with the transpose on here
and instead of doing it this way we
might need to do something called
flattening why would you flatten your
data if this is an array going into a
neural network
you might want to send it in as one set
of values instead of two rows and you
can see here is all the values as a
single array it just flattens it down
into one array
so we covered our scientific means
transpose median some different
variations on here some of the other
things we want to do is what happens if
we want to append to our array so let's
create a new array
I'm getting tired of looking at the same
set of random numbers we generated
earlier so we'll go ahead and create a
new array here something a little
simpler so it's easier to see what we're
doing
and four five six seven eight uh that's
good enough we'll just do four five six
seven eight
and if we print this array
there it is four five six seven eight
and we might want to append something to
the array so we have our array we need
to extend it you got to be very careful
about appending things to your array and
there's a number of reasons for that
one is runtime because of the way the
numpy ray is set up a lot of times you
build your data and then push it into
the numpy array instead of continually
adding on to the array
and then it also usually it
automatically generates a copy for
protecting your data so there's a lot of
reasons to be careful about appending
this way but you can certainly do it and
we can just take our array we're going
to create a new array array one
and if we print array one and we append
8 to it you'll see four five six seven
and then there's our a depended on to
the end
and if you want to append something to
an array you'd probably also want to
whoops
array one let's try that again there we
go now we have the a dependent on to the
end
so you can see four five six seven eight
and then we pinned it another eight on
there
and if you're going to append something
you might want to um
go ahead and insert instead of appending
it might be you need to keep a certain
order and we can do the same thing we do
our array
and we're going to pin or insert at the
beginning and let's go ahead and insert
uh one two three one two three and we go
ahead and print our array two we run it
and you can see one two three a pin is
inserted at the beginning
inserts a lot more powerful and that you
can put it anywhere in the array we can
move it to the one spot and there we go
one two three we can do a minus one
just for fun and you'll see it comes up
one two three and we're counting
backwards by one
I imagine you can do minus zero
and run this and it turns out that minus
zero puts it back at the beginning
because that's why it registers a zero
just takes a minus sign off
and just like we add numbers on we might
want to delete numbers and so let's do
an NP dot delete well let's keep it a
little bit make it a little easy here to
watch we'll go ahead and create an array
three
then we'll do NP delete we're just
working with array 2
and we want to do is delete zero space
so if we look at this here's our array
two our Raid 2 starts with one and when
we delete the space on here
and print that out we deleted the one
right out of there
and we can also do something like this
where we can do it as a slice and we can
do let's do one comma three
and if we run one comma three you'll see
we've deleted the one space
and the three space out which deleted
our two and four
now keep in mind when you're messing
with adding lines and deleting lines
you have to be really careful because
there's a time element involved as far
as where the data is coming from and
it's really easy to delete the wrong
data and corrupt what you're working on
or to insert stuff where you don't want
it so there's always a warning when we
talk about manipulating numpy arrays
and just like anything else we're doing
we'll create an array C which equals
we'll just do our our numpy array that
we just created our Olympia array 3 and
we can do copy so you can make a copy of
it maybe you want to protect your
original data or maybe you're making a
mask and so you copy the array and then
the new array make all these alterations
and change it from values to zero to one
to mask over the first one and of course
we if we do array C since it equals a
copy of array three it's the same thing
one three five six seven eight
and now we're getting into combine and
split arrays
I end up doing a lot of this
and I don't know how many times I end up
fiddling with this and having a mess
so but but you do it a lot you know you
combine the arrays you split them you
might need one set of data for one thing
another set of data for the other
so let's go ahead and create two arrays
array one array two
and I want you to note
in the terminology we're going to look
for is concatenate what that means is
we're going to take
um
we'll call this a raycat I like a ray
cat there we go our array cat our
concatenated array
we're taking array one and two
and it's very important to really pay
attention to your axes and your accounts
I can't merge two arrays that have like
if their axes are messed up and I'm
merging on axis zero it's going to give
me an error and I'll have to reshape
them so you got to make sure that
whatever you're concatenating together
works
and what that means
as you can see here we have one two
three four one two three four and then
five six seven eight five six seven
eight along the zero axis
these each are four values
um so it's a two by four value and if we
go ahead and switch this to one you can
see how that's that flips it a little
bit so now we have one two three four
five six seven eight
it's interesting that we chose that one
if I did something like this
where this is now
there we go and we concatenate it let me
run this and it gives me an answer okay
because I have two by two and I'm using
axes one but if I switch this to axis
zero where now it's got three and five
it gives me an error so you got to be
really careful on that to make sure that
your whatever axes you are putting
together that they match so like I said
this one oops X is one axis one has two
entities and since we're going on axes
one or by row you can see that it lets
it merge it right onto the end there
and you could imagine this if this was a
x y plot of value or the x value going
in and the predicted y value coming out
and then you have another prediction and
you want to combine them this works
really easy for that
and we'll go back and let's just put
this back to where we had it
oops I forgot how many changes I made
there we go
um we'll just put it whoops I messed up
in my concatenation order here
[Music]
we go
okay so you can see that we went through
the different concatenation axes is
really important when you're doing your
concatenation values on here
and we'll switch us back to one just
because I like the looks of that better
there we go two rows
now there are other commands in here so
we can do cat V
equals npv v stack
this is nothing more than your
concatenation
but instead we don't have to put the
axes in there because it's v stands for
vertical and so if we print out
cat
V and we run this
you can see we get the one two three
four one two three four and that would
be the same as making this axis zero for
vertical stack and if you're going to
have a vertical stack you can also have
an H stack
so if we change this to from v-stack to
oops here we go H stack and we'll just
change this from cat to cat
and I run this
it's the same as doing axis zero the
process is identical in the background
this is like a legacy setup your v-stack
and your H stack most people just use
concatenate and then put the axes in
there because this much has a lot more
clarity and is more more commonly used
nowadays
the last section in numpy we're going to
cover is
under is kind of data exploration and
that'll make a little bit more sense in
just a moment sometimes they call them
set operations but let's say we have an
array one two three four five six three
whatever it is I think so we generate a
nice little array here and what I want
to go ahead and do is find the unique
values in that array
so maybe I'm generating what they call
it one hot encoder and so these values
then all become I need to know how long
my bit Ray is going to be so each word
how many how many each word is
represented by a number and then I want
to know just how many of those words are
in there if we're doing word count very
popular thing to do
and you can see here when we do unique
uh we have one two three four five six
those are our unique values
uh some of the things we can do with the
unique values is we can also instead of
doing just unique we can do uniques
our unique values and counts of each
unique value
and this is very similar to what we just
did up here where we we're doing NP
unique but we're going to add a little
bit more into there
and it's just part of the arguments in
this and we want to do return
counts equals
true so instead of just returning the
unique values we want to know how many
of those unique values are in each one
and we'll go ahead and print
our uniques
and print
our counts
let me run that you can see here we have
our unique value one two three four five
six just like we had before and then
there's two of the first of two ones two
twos two threes two fours one five two
sixes and so on and you can go through
and actually look at that if you want to
count them but a quick way to find out
your distribution of different values so
you might want to know how often the
word the is used versus the word and if
each word is represented as a unique
number
and along the set variables we might
want to know let me just put a note up
here
we're going to start looking at
uh intersection
and we might want to also know
differentiation
and neither
so when we're whoops neighbor
so what we're looking at now is we want
to know hey where do these two arrays
intersect and we have one two three four
five three four five six seven we might
want to know what is common between the
two arrays
and so when we do that we have NP
intersect
and it's a 1D array one dimensional
array
and then we need to go ahead and put
array 1 array two
and if we run this
we can see they intersect at three four
five that's what they have common
and because we're going to go ahead and
go through these and look at a couple
different options let's change this from
intersect 1D
and we'll do the same thing I'm going to
print this
so we might want to know the
intersection where they have
commonalities
another unique word is Union of 1D so
instead of intersect
we want to know all the values that are
in both of them so here's our Union of
1D when we run that you can see we have
one two three four five six seven so
it's all the different values in there
and the last one of the last words we
have two more to go as we want to know
what the set difference is
uh and so that's where the you'll see
that if you remember set we talked about
that being the what they call these
things so the set difference
have a 1D array we run that you can see
that one is only in one array and two is
only in one array
and if we want to know uh what's in
Array 1 but not in Array 2 we might want
to know what is in Array one but not two
and what's in two but not one
and this would be the set X or 1D on
here so we have the four different
options here where we can do an
intersection what do they both have in
common we can do a union what are all
the unique values in both arrays
we can see the difference what's in
Array one but not array two so set diff
1D and then set X or what is not in one
but is in two and what is in not in two
but in one
so we dug a lot in numpy because we're
talking there's a lot of different
little mathematical things going on in
numpy a lot of this can also be done in
pandas although usually the heavy
lifting is left for numpy because that's
what it's designed for let's go ahead
and open up another Python 3
setup in here
and so we want to explore what happens
when you want to display this this is
where it starts getting in my opinion a
little fun because you're actually
playing with it and you have something
to show people and we'll go ahead and
rename this we're going to call this uh
pandas and Pi plot
so pandas pipelot just so we can
remember for next time and we want to go
ahead and import the necessary libraries
we're going to import pandas as PD now
remember this is a data frame so we're
talking rows and columns and you'll see
how pandas work so nicely when you're
actually showing data to people and then
we're going to have numpy in the
background numpy works with pandas so a
lot of times you just import them by
default
Seaborn sits on top of the matplot
library so sometimes we use the Seaborn
because it kind of extends it's one of
the 100 packages it extends the matplot
library probably the most common used
because it has a lot of built-in
functionality almost by default I
usually just put Seaborn in there in
case I need it and of course we have
matplot Library as pipelot as PLT and
note we have as PD as NP as SNS as PLT
those are pretty standard so when you're
doing your Imports I would probably keep
those just so other people can read your
code and it makes sense to them that's
pretty much a standard nowadays
and then we have the strange line here
it says ambersign matplot Library inline
that is for Jupiter notebook only so if
you're running this in a different
package you'll have a pop-up when it
goes to display the matplot library you
can with the most current version of
Jupiter usually leave that out and it
will still display it right on the page
as we go and we'll see what that looks
like
and then we're going to go ahead and
just do the Seaborn the sns.set and
we're going to set the color codes
equals true let them just keep the
default one so we don't have to think
about it too much
and we of course have to run this the
reason we run this is because these
values are all set if we don't run this
and I access one of these afterward
it'll crash
the cool thing about Jupiter notebooks
is if you forgot to import one of these
you forgot to install it because you do
have to install this under your anaconda
setup or whatever setup you're in you
can flip over to Anaconda and run your
install for these and then just come
back and run it you don't have to close
anything out
and we'll go ahead and paste this one in
here real quick where we have car equals
PD dot read underscore CSV and then we
have the actual path
this path of course will vary depending
on what you are working with so it's
wherever you saved the file at and you
can see here I have um like my OneDrive
documents simply Learn Python data
analytics using python slash car CSV
it's quite a long file
when we open that up what we get is we
get a CSV file and we have the make the
model the year the engine fuel type
engine horsepower cylinders and so on
and this is just a comma separated file
so each row is like a row of data think
of it as a spreadsheet
and then each one is a column of data on
here and as you can see right here it
has the make model so it has columns for
a header on here
now your pandas just does an excellent
job of automatically pulling a lot of
this in so when you start seeing the
pandas on here you realize that you are
already like halfway done with getting
your data in I just love pandas for that
reason numpy also has it you can load a
CSV directly into numpy but we're
working with pandas and this is where it
really gets cool is I can come down here
and I can print remember our print
statement we can actually get rid of it
and we're just going to do car head
because it's going to print that out the
head is going to print the top values of
that data file we just ran in
and so you can see right here it does a
nice printout it's all nice and in line
because we're in Jupiter notebook I can
scroll back and forth and look at the
different data and just like we expected
we have our column and it brought the
header right in
one thing to note is the index it
automatically created an index 0 1 2 3 4
and so on and we're just looking at the
head so we've got zero one two three
four
you can change this you might want to
just look at the top two
we can run that there's our top two BMWs
another thing we can do is instead of
head we can do tail
and look at the last three values that
are in that data file and you can see
right here numbered them all the way up
to
11913 oh my goodness they put a lot of
data in this file I didn't even look to
see how big the file was so you can
really easily get through and view the
different data in here when you're
talking about Big Data
you almost never just print out car in
fact let's see what happens when we do
if we run this and we just run the car
it's huge in fact it's so big that the
pandas automatically truncates it and
just does head plus tail so you can see
the two so we really don't want to look
at the whole thing I'm going to go back
to let's stick with the head
displaying our data there we go so
there's ahead of our data gives us a
quick look to see what's actually in
there I can zoom out if we want so you
can actually get a better View
although we'll keep it zoomed in so you
can see the code I'm working on
and then from the data standpoint we of
course want to look at
data types what's going on with our data
what does it look like now this you know
you show your when you're talking to
your shareholders they like to see these
nice easy to read charts they look like
a spreadsheet so it's a nice way of
displaying pieces of the chart
we talk about the data types now we're
getting into the data science side of it
what are we working with well we have
make model we have an integer 64 for the
year engine fuel type is an object if we
go up here you can see that there most
of them are
like you know it's a set manual rear
wheel drive so they might be very
limited number of types in there
and so forth and it's either going to be
a float 64 an integer or an object just
the way it's going to read it on here
and the next thing you're going to know
is like your columns
and since it loaded the columns
automatically we have here the make the
model the year the engine the size all
the way up to the MSRP
and um just out of something you'll see
come up a lot is whenever you're in
pandas and you type in dot values it
converts it from a pandas list to a
numpy array
and that's true of any of these so then
you end up in an empty array so you'll
see a little switch in there in the way
that the data is actually stored and
that's true of any of these
in this case we want car dot columns
they have a total list of your car
columns
and like any good data scientist we want
to start looking at analytical summary
of the data set what's going on with our
data so we can start trying to piecemeal
it together so we can do car
describe
and then we'll do is we'll do include
equals
all
so a nice Panda command is to describe
your data
if you're working with r this should
start looking familiar
and we come down here and you can see
count there's a make the model of the
year how many of each one how many
unique values of each one the top value
of each one what's most common the
frequency the mean clearly on some of
these it's an object so really can't
tell you what the average is it'd just
be the top ones the average I guess
the year what's the average year on
there all this stuff comes down here
your standard deviation your minimum
value your maximum value what's in the
lower quarter fifty percent Mark where's
that line at and what's in the upper 75
percent the top 25 percent going into
the max
now this next part is just cool this is
what we always wanted computers be back
like in the 90s instead of 5 000 lines
of code to do this maybe not five
thousand all right I built my own plot
Library back in 95 and the amount of
code for doing a simple plot was um
I don't know probably about 100 lines of
code
this is being done in one line of code
we have our car which is our pandas we
generated that it's our data frame and
we have dot hist for histogram that is
the power of Seaborn now it's still
going to generate a numpy graph but
Seaborn sits on top and then we can do
the figure size this is just um so it
fits nicely on the paper on here and we
do something simple like this and you
can see here where it comes up and does
say matplot library and does subplots
and everything
but we're looking at a histogram of all
the different pieces in our database and
we have our engine cylinders that's
always a good one because you can see
like they have some that are they had a
null on there so they came out as zero
maybe a couple maybe one of them had a
two cylinder engine away back when four
is a common six a little less common and
then you see the eight cylinder 12
cylinder engines whether it's got to be
a Speedster or something
uh but you can see right here just
breaks it down so now you have how many
cars with how many whatever it is
cylinders horsepower and so on and it
does a nice job displaying it
you can see if you're working with your
uh um you're going into your demo it's
really nice just to be able to type that
in and boom there it is it can see it
all the way across
and we might want to zero in and use
like a box plot and this time we'll go
ahead and call the Seaborn SNS box plot
and we're going to go ahead and do
vehicle size in versus engine horsepower
XY plot and the data comes from the car
so if we run this we end up with a nice
box plot
you see our mid-size Compact and large
you can see the variation there's our
outlier showing up there on the compact
that must be a high-end sports car a
large car might have a couple engines
and again we have all these outliers and
then your deviation on them
very powerful and quick way to zero in
on one small piece of data and display
it for people who need to have it
reduced to something they can see and
look at and understand and that's our
Seabourn box plot or sns.box plot
and then if we're going to back out and
we want a quick look at what they call
pair plotting we can run that and you
can see with the Seaborn it just does
all the work for you
it takes it just a moment for it to pull
the data in and compile it
and once it does it creates a nice Grid
in this grid if you look at this one
space here which is you might not be
able to see the small number it says
engine horsepower this is engine
horsepower uh to the year was built and
it's just flipped so everything to the
right of the middle diagonal is just the
rotation of what's on the left and as
you expect the engine horsepower gets
bigger and bigger and bigger as time
goes on so the the year it was built the
further up in the year the more likely
you are to have a heavy horsepower
engine
and you can quickly look at trends
with our pair plot coming up and look
how fast that was that was it took a
couple a moment to process but right
away I get a nice view of all these
different information which I can look
at visually in and kind of see how
things group and look
now if I was doing a meeting I probably
wouldn't show all the data
one of the things I've learned over the
years is people myself included love to
show all our work you know we were
taught in school show all your work
prove what you know the CEO doesn't want
to see a huge grid of graphs I guarantee
it so we want to do is we want to go
ahead and drop
um the stuff that might not be
interested in and we're gonna I'm not
really a car person a guy in the back is
obviously so you have your engine fuel
type we're going to drop that we're
going to drop Market category vehicle
style popularity number of doors vehicle
size and we have the axes in here if you
remember from numpy we have to include
that axis to make it clear what we're
working on that's also true with pandas
and then we'll look at just the what it
looks like um from the head
and you can see that we dropped out
those categories and now we have the
make model year and so forth and we took
out the engine fuel type Market category
Etc
and this should look familiar to you now
when you start working with pandas I
just love pandas for this reason look
how easy it is it just displays it as a
nice spreadsheet for you you can just
look at it and view it very easily it's
also the same kind of view you're going
to get if you're working in spark or Pi
spark which is python for spark across
Big Data this is the kind of thing that
they they come up with this is why
pandas is so powerful
and we may look at this and decide we
don't like these columns and so you can
go in here and we can actually rename
the columns
simple command car equals car rename
columns equals engine horsepower equals
horsepower this is just your standard
python dictionary
so it just Maps them out and you know
instead of having like a lengthy here we
had engine horsepower we just won
horsepower we don't need to know it's
the engine horsepower
engine cylinders we don't need to know
that it's for the engine because there's
only one thing we're describing if we're
talking about cars and that cylinders
and we'll go ahead and just run this and
again here's our car head and you can
see how that changed we have model year
and horsepower versus model year engine
horsepower engine cylinders and just
cylinders
again we want to keep reducing this so
it's more and more readable the more
readable you get it the better and of
course we can also adjust the size a
little bit
so that when it prints out instead of
splitting it on two lines we get like a
single line we can do that also that's
just your control Mouse app or plus sign
you use in Chrome that's a chrome
command
and if you remember from numpy we had
shape well pandas works the same way we
can look at the shape of the data so we
now have 11 914 rows and 10 columns so
you see some similarities because pandas
is built on numpy
and questions that come up just like you
did in numpy we might want to know
duplicate rows and so we can do car and
look at this switch here
um we're doing a selection this is a
panda selection with the brackets
but we want to select it based on
car.duplicated so how many duplicates on
there
so it's starting to look a little bit
different as far as how we access some
of the data in here this can be a
logical statement and we get the number
of duplicate rows we have 989 rows by 10
columns again
and this is one of those troubleshooting
things that we end up doing a lot more
than we really feel like we should we
might go ahead and do like a car count
just to see how many rows we're dealing
with and then right after that we might
want to go ahead and say hey let's drop
duplicates so remember we did all the
duplicates on there so car equals car
dot drop duplicates and then we can
print the head again we'll just do car
head here and you can see the data on
there looks the same as before
and just note that we did car equals car
draw duplicates there are commands in
here where you can do where it changes
the actual value and it works on some of
them and not on others depending on what
you're doing but by default it always
returns a copy so when we do this we're
reassigning it to car
and you can see it's the same header but
we want to go ahead and do count and see
how the count changes let's go ahead and
run this and you can see here instead of
11 914 we have 10 925. so we've removed
about a hundred cars that were
duplicated just slightly under 100 there
and then as we're prepping our data we
might want to know
um car is null so it's going to count
the values of null and then we want to
sum that up and when we do that we do
the car is null function dot sum we end
up with HP the horsepower 69 have null
values and 30 have cylinders have no
values now if you don't put the sum at
the end it's just going to return a mask
with the true false of is it null or is
it not by the zero and one so you're
summing up the ones underneath each
column
and this of course then you have to
decide what you're going to do with the
null values there's a lot of different
options it might be that you need to put
in the average or means
maybe you want to put in the median
value there's a lot of different ways to
fill it usually when you first start out
with the data a lot of them you just
drop your null values and you can see
here car dot drop in a
which is equal to all and then we're
going to go ahead and count it and you
can see that we've dropped almost
another 100 values so from 10 1925 to 10
8 27.
and maybe 75 or so values
so we cleaned that this is really a big
part of cleaning data you need to know
how to get rid of your null values or at
least count them and what to do with
them
and of course if we go back to um
counting our null values we should now
have
no no values there we go and you'll see
there's zero null values
I don't know how many times I've been
running a model that doesn't take null
values and it crashes and I just sit
there and look at it trying to get why
did that crash it should have worked
it's because I forgot to remove the null
values
so we've been jumping around a lot we're
going to go back to finding outliers and
let's go ahead and bring that back into
our Seaborn and if you remember we did a
box plot earlier this time we're going
to do a box plot just on the price and
you can see here our price value
and we have the deviation with the two
thinner bars on each side of the main
value and then as we get up here we have
all these outliers in fact we have one
way out here that's um probably a really
expensive high-end car is what we're
looking at
if you were doing fraud analysis you
would be jumping on all over these
outliers why are these deviation from
the standard what are these people doing
again this is probably like I said a
really high-end expensive car out here
that's what we're looking at and we can
also look at the box plot for the
horsepower
and we'll put that in down here
and run that
and you can see again here's our
horsepower and it just jumps and there's
these really odd huge muscle cars out
here that are outliers
and we're going to jump into making this
a little bit more as you started
displaying your data or your information
to your shareholders we're going to look
at plotting a histogram for the number
of cars per brand
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do is we have with our car we'll go
back over here here we go we have our
make value counts largest plot and we
want to do a kind equals bar
fig size 10-5
and right off the bat we jump up here we
see Chevrolet it's going against what
was it it's um figure resolution the
value counts and we want the largest
value so here's our value counts and
compared to what the different cars are
Chevrolet puts out a lot of different
kinds of cars I didn't realize that they
made that many cars or different types
and then for readability let's go ahead
and add a title number of cars by make
number of cars and make if you looked at
this the first time you would have been
like well what the heck am I looking at
well we're looking at the number of cars
by make and then you can see here now
we're talking about the type of cars and
the different ones are put out Lotus I
guess only had a few different kinds of
cars over there very high-end cars
and then as uh doing data analytics and
as a data scientist one of the things I
am most interested in is the
relationship between the variables
so this is always a place to start we
want to know what's going on with our
variables and how they connect with each
other
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and set a figure
size because we want to make sure it
fits our graph we'll just go ahead and
set this one plot Figure Set to figure
size 2010. if you never use the matplot
library which is sitting behind Seaborn
whatever is in the PLT this is what's
loaded it's like a canvas you're
painting on so the second you load that
Pi plot as PLT anything you do to that
is affecting everything on it
uh and then we want to go ahead since
we're using Seaborn
we'll go ahead and create a variable C
for relationships or correspondence
and car dot c-o-r-r that's a correlation
in Seaborn on top of pandas again one
line and you get the whole correlation
on there and because we're working with
Seabourn let's put it into a nice heat
map if you're not familiar with heat
maps that means we're just using color
as part of our
setup so we have a nice visual
and we can see here that the Seaborn
connected to the pandas prints out a
nice chart
we'll talk a little bit about the color
here in a second it prints out a nice
chart this is a chart I look at as a
data scientist these are the numbers I
want to look at and we'll just highlight
one of them here's cylinders versus
horsepower the closer to one the higher
the correlation so 0.788 pretty high
correlation between the number of
cylinders and how heavy the horsepower
is
I'm betting if you looked at the year
versus horsepower we just look at that
one here's year and horsepower 0.314 not
as so much but if you combine them you
don't actually add them but if you
combine them you'll start to see an
increase in Horsepower per year and
cylinders you could probably get a
correlation there and just like 0.78 is
a positive correlation you might notice
if we look at cylinders
and or let's look at horsepower and
mileage so if we go here to horsepower
to mileage you get a nice negative we'll
do cylinders that's a bigger number
with cylinders to the miles per gallon
it's a minus 0.6 so it's a negative
correlation the closer to -1 the more
the negative correlation is
and then the chart you would actually
show people is a nice heat map this is
all our colors and it's just those
numbers put into a heat map the darker
the color the higher the correlation you
can see straight down the middle
obviously the year correlates strictly
with the year horsepower with horsepower
and so on that's why it's a one the
closer to the one the higher the
correlation between the two pieces of
data
now this is a good introduction pandas
goes Way Beyond this most the
functionality in numpy since pandas sits
on it is also in pandas and then it even
has additional features in it and we use
Seaborn pretty extensively sitting on
top over our pie plot so keep in mind
that our PI plot has a ton of other
features in it that we didn't even touch
on in here we couldn't even if you had a
sole course in it there's just so many
things hidden in there depending on what
your domain you're working on but you
can see here here's our Seaborn and
here's our matplot library that's all
our Graphics that we did and then the
Seaborn works really nicely with the
pandas we really like that
hi everyone
python is one of the emerging
programming languages according to the
most recent figures python is the most
used coding language for about 80
percent of developers the syntax of this
high level programming language is
simple to understand Python's large
Library System makes it a best choice
for data science machine learning and
artificial intelligence projects and let
us have a simple quiz question to brush
upon our knowledge and your question is
which keyword is used for function in
Python language and your options are
your first option is function and second
option is DF
third is f u n or fourth is defined you
can pause the video give it a thought
and answer in the comment section below
and we will update the correct answer in
the print command to do the financial
analysis first we'll go to our python
projects and this is our data on which
we would be doing the financial analysis
and I will provide you the link in the
description box for this sheet also so
this sheet indicates that the genders
male and female how they invest and what
stage their investment in mutual funds
Equity Market debentures government
bonds and fixed deposits
and at how much duration and how they
invest daily monthly weekly so we would
be doing financial analysis on this
sheet so starting with
first we will create a folder
and name it as financial
analysis financial analysis yeah I was
going to make a spelling mistake but I
didn't
so here we will open our Jupiter
notebook in which we're going to proceed
with our financial analysis you could
use any ideally you want to use I would
be using the Jupiter notebook for that I
will open the command prompt and write
the command
Jupiter and notebook
and we'll get our Jupiter notebook open
in the browser
till then it's loading
we would
move a CSV file
into a folder only
financial analysis
so it would be easy for us to do
some tasks like
we can easily provide the link for the
CSV file
now moving to a Jupiter notebook we have
Finance underscore data.csv in a folder
now we'll create a new file
and Name It We Will name it as
binance analysis
now starting with
the first thing we should do is import
our libraries or import our modules
and first module we would be using would
be numpy
and we would be importing that and to
install that you could just simply
go on the folder
call the command prompt and write pip
install
numpy
you can easily find these
commands to install any module on the
web or you can just see like what I
would be installing and you could see
that the requirement is already
satisfied as I have already installed
the numpy and all other module that
would be using in our in this tutorial
so you could just go to the command
prompt and write the command and the
module would be installed for you
now we will move back to our Jupiter
notebook and start importing our
packages
and the first package we have seen the
command to install it and now we will
import it that would be numpy we'll
import numpy and use the Lis s NP and
the second package would be importing
would be pandas
with that we'll write the command import
pandas
and we will
also use the Allies here and lose SPD
and you can install the pandas Library
by using the command pip install pandas
or you could just simply search on the
web you would get the commands there
also so I will run this command
that's clear that our commands have been
run successfully so moving on now you
would see uh how many files are present
in a folder in which we are making this
python notebook
so for that we will first import the OS
module and you can simply install it by
using the command that would be pip
install Os or for OS it would be pip
install sys uh
hyphen OS so you could simply search on
the web or I would show you
I would open an incognito window for you
and
pip install
OS
python
so you could see this is the official
website for
OS module you could simply visit on that
and you could simply copy the command
that is OS
iPhone sys and just open the command and
paste on your command prompt it would be
installing your command easily or you
could also paste that command into your
Jupiter notebook it would do the same
task for you now we want all the files
set up present in our folder so for that
we'll write
four
directory name
comma
underscore comma
file names
in
OS dot work
and inside the curly braces
we would write the path
for our folder
and we could simply copy the path of the
folder from here
it's showing cmd.exe right so I will go
back
and now I'll copy the path
and we'll paste it here and after the
curly braces I will just place a colon
and after that
all right
I will run a loop
it would be 4
file name
in file names
we would be printing
OS dot path dot join
and inside the brackets we will pass the
directory name and the file name
okay
and now we'll just click on run you
could see that it's showing three files
that is finance underscore data.csv and
the ipy NB file that has been created by
us that is financial analysis and the
checkpoints that the jupyter notebook
creates
and moving on we would be installing
some other modules and
first
I will tell you about numpy that it's an
open source and general purpose array
processing package it offers a
multi-dimensional array object with
outstanding speed as well as tools for
interacting with these arrays
and about pandas so pandas is an open
source Library designed primarily for
working quickly and intuitively with
relational or labeled data it offers a
range of data structures and procedures
for working with time series and
numerical data and this library is built
on top of the numpy library and it's
quick and offers its users exceptional
performance and productivity and now we
would be installing the matte blue lip
I've already installed so I would be
importing it matplotlib library and the
C Boon Library
so for that I would write the command
and before importing I want to walk
through with this so OS dot work
function it generates the file names in
a directory Tree by working the tree
either top down or bottom up for each
directory in the two in the tree rooted
at the directory top it yields a three
double that is directory path directory
name and the file name
so moving on now we'll install our
modules and that would be
C bone and matplotlip
so for C bone you could easily write the
command or you can search on the web how
to install it so for that the command
would be a pip installs keyboard
so we would be
importing it
import C bone
and we'll be using the Allies here
as SNS
and now we'll be using the pipeload
library
pipelout class or the matplotlib library
so for that you would write the command
met dot lib
and we'll be using the pipe load
and analyze for this as PLT
so we would be using these two libraries
also and we have run the command and it
has been executed successfully at it has
turned the number to three
no
if I tell you about C bone so C bone is
a library for making statistical
Graphics in Python and it builds on top
of matplotlip and integrates closely
with pandas data structures and C bone
helps you explore an entrance it helps
you understand your data its plotting
functions operate on data frames and
arrays containing whole data sets and
internally perform the necessary
semantic mapping and statistical
aggregation to produce information Proto
its data set oriented declarative API
lets you focus on what the different
elements of your plots mean rather than
on the details of how to draw them you
could easily draw them so you don't have
to think like how to draw them you could
just simply import this library and
start a functioning
now moving on we have Simone Library
also so it's a python data visualization
library that is based on matplotlab it
provides a high level interface for
doing interactive and informative
statistical graphics
as now we have imported all the
libraries we can start with a project
and first thing we would be doing is we
would set the default style that is
would set the style function
that would be used for plot styling and
for that we would be using the allies of
C bone
and use the function set underscore
Style
and
will Mark as dark grid
we'll run this so it has been executed
successfully as you can see that the
number has turned out to be 4.
so now
we would read the file that is a CSV
file and to read that we would declare a
variable and named as DF and we'll use
the pandas library to read that and
write the command PD dot read
underscore CSV and inside the silicone
braces we would
write the path for the file
so we'll copy the path and in the
inverted commas we will paste the path
and at last we could just write the file
name
and the file name was Finance underscore
data
dot CSV
so here spelling is
Finance I have written the wrong
spelling for the file but it's okay
we'll use the same
fine and
underscore data dot CSV
so now
we'll just run this
and you could see that our file has been
loaded so
as you can see our file is already
loaded and the reads underscore CSV
function it takes a path to a CSV file
and reads the data into a pandas data
frame object now we will be using the DF
dot head function
and run it
so what does this function do so it is
used to get the first n rows that is
this function Returns the first n rows
for the object based on position it is
useful for quickly testing if your
object has the right type of data in it
so it has
shown us that is the five
rows and mostly all the columns and it's
showing you that five rows close 24
columns there are 24 columns here and it
has shown you all the columns now I will
drop some columns from the sheet and to
drop them we will write a command that
would be TF in which we have stored the
sheet
the DF variable
and inside that we will write
command that is drop and inside the
circular braces we would write the
columns we want to drop
and the name would be we will drop
columns that would be mutual funds
Equity Market
debentures government bonds fixed
deposits ppf gold
so we'll drop these columns
and
to drop them we will write the name of
the columns in the Square braces
so first we'll write the name of the
mutual funds
let's skip pattern Mutual ones Mutual
underscore fun story
which are underscore funds
and
then next we want to drop is equity
Market
for that we will write Equity Market
that is in inverted commas and Ms
capital for Equity Market
no debentures
and that two in inverted commas
[Music]
the next was government bonds fixed
deposits ppf and gold
okay so in inverted commas you write
comment bonds
and then it was ppf
and it was fixed deposits and there was
gold also
foreign
now we have listed all the columns that
we want to drop and now
we would set the axis equal to 1 that is
from the same axis x equal x is equal to
1 these all the columns would be
identified and they would be dropped and
they would be strong stored in the DF
variable
so for that we'll write
we'll set the axis
and X's would be equal to
and we'll set in place
that would be equal to
true
Okay so now
run this command
okay and mean equal to equal to
is so videos
equal to zero
just find out
we will just restart it
now after restarting we'll try to run it
okay so there is
you know equal to cells
[Music]
X is equal to 1 and
and press is equal to okay uh
circular bracket would be closed here
yeah
our Command has been executed
successfully as you can see in the
Square braces we have a number eight
that means the command has been
successfully executed and we have
dropped these columns and now moving on
we'll use the replace function that
would be the pandas replace function and
we will replace all the empty columns
with n n that is node a number value and
for that we'll write a command DF that
is TF equal to DF dot replace
and inside
we will write command
dollar
and
this would be enclosed in the inverted
commas
and come afterwards
and NP Dot N A N what we want and then
set regex that is equal to
true
and now if we run this it has been
executed successfully and the replace
function it replaces all the occurrence
of matched pattern in the string and a
regular expression that is rejects we
have used here that is equal to true
it's a sequence of characters that
Define a search pattern and filter rows
is pandas like to filter rows in pandas
by regex we can use the string dot match
method
now moving on
here we would start with the floating
and we will use the C bone
and
we will draw our first plot that would
be the power plot only
and for that would we will use count
plot function
count plot and we'll set the x parameter
as gender
you could see in the shield gender where
we are setting it as X
and the next thing we would set would be
data that is we would take the data from
the variable DF in which we have stored
the file that is the CSV file and line
width
for the plot and we'll set it as
three
and then we'll set the palette
and that would be equal to
set to
and then we'll set the edge color
and that would be black
and after that we would use the function
that would be PLT dot show
and we'll run the command
as you can see that we have set the x
parameter as gender and count so it's
showing
how many males and females are investing
at
like what are the numbers in this sheet
how many males are investing and how
many females are investing
so moving on
and first if we see
in here so we have used the count plot
function that is the method used to show
the counts of observation in each
categorial bin using bars and we have
set the x that is the parameter that
takes names of variables in data or
vector data
optional inputs that is used for
plotting long form data and we have used
palette that takes the value of the
pellet and it is mostly used to show the
Hue variable and what is U here U is the
parameter that specifies the column name
and we have said the data is equal to DF
that is the parameter that defines the
data frame that we would like to take
for the representation for instance data
can be an array
and moving on
we will draw another plot
using the Simone only and the count plot
function
so sns.count plot and inside we will
pass X parameter equal to H
and then we'll pass the data that would
be equal to
DF and set the palette
that would be equal to
set 3
and then we will set line width
that is equal to 2 and then we'll set
the edge color
of the
plot that is the bar graph
we will set the edge color
that would be black
and now we will run this
you could see
that it has
X level s h and y label as count
that is at how many age men and women
both combine are investing at the age of
to women or men like two people we would
say we won't
make it consideration as gender here so
we are just counting how many people are
investing at which age
so
moving on
now we'll move to another plot and
draw something related to age only
and you could also use PLT or show to
just get your
output
if you're right here PLT don't show
it will give you the same output and
here now it's not showing the x-axis and
then Y axis you could easily see here
but it's defining
now moving on
now we'll draw a figure and using the
matte plot lip and here we will be using
two plots
and I would like you would understand
with
this only first we'll draw it and then I
will explain what I want to show you so
first we will use the Metro clip allies
that would be PLT dot figure and inside
we are passing fig size that would be
equal to
18 comma 6.
and after that I will be using the
subplot that is
we would be drawing two plots here and
for one subplot
LT dot subplot inside we would pass the
parameters for this upload
the first we have defined the figure
size the whole figure and inside there
will be two plots and inside those plots
what would be the size for one plot so
that would be defined by PLT dot subplot
and now
sns.count plot
we would
draw count plot here and inside we will
pass the X parameter
that is equal to DF and inside we will
pass the column that would be gender
and
here we'll set the view
that is equal to DF
and inside the bracket that is a square
bracket
you would write the
investment of menus
that
who will are investing
and Mr underscore yeah they will
underscore investment underscore
Avenues
and now we have set the U here
and now we'll set the palette
to set the palette
we would set the palette as summer
and after setting the palette we'll set
the line width
for the upload that is the bar and would
set as three and after that would set
the edge color
and Edge color would be equal to
White
and now we'll give the title to this
upload only this upload and for that we
would write a command PLT dot title
and inside this title
we would write
investment
venue
and after that
we will draw another subplot that would
be PLT Dot
subplot and
for that we will Define the parameters
that would mean comma 2 comma 1
to
and we'll use
sns.count plot
and inside we set the x parameter that
would be DF
and inside the square brackets we define
gender
and set the hue
that would be equal to DF
and inside
you would
write for the stock market
stock market
and
now we'll set the palette
and we'll set the palette as
hold only
now after setting the palette we would
set the line width
remember to the plot that would be equal
to 3 and after line bit we would set
Edge color
that would be equal to White
and after that we would set the title
for it
PLT Dot
title
and site title we would set it as
stock market
and use the function PLT Dot
show
to show both the graphs now I'll run
this command
and we go down that is token.com Market
so we'll check
okay americ
so we have the column name here MRK
t-e-t
so we'll use the same
and run it
so you could see there are two subplots
and they are inside the figure that is
of the value 18 comma 6 and here we have
gender and count that is investment
venue who all are investing
and here we have who all are investing
in the stock market and according to the
gender
I can females
how many are
investing in stock market they are
indicated by red color and those who are
not investing they are indicated by
yellow color
and same with the men
and if you see we have used a pig size
here that is a tuple of the width and
height of the figure in inches
and we have set the inches here and
subplot that means groups of axes that
can exist in a single matplotlib figure
and subplots function is the mat that is
stored in the metro.lib library and
helps in creating multiple layouts of
sub loads and it provides control over
all the individual plots that are
created
and we have created that
now moving on we will create another
account plot using the C bone and for
that we'll write the command sns.count
plot
and inside will pass the X parameter
that would be equal to DF and
inside would pass vector
check with
a sheet
and that is the factor so we will pass
this and set the pilot for it and line
width and Edge color and we'll draw the
account plot so the factor is
how the people are
investing like they are looking for
returns or they are investing for
locking period so that their investment
could be stored for longer period of
time or they are disking their
investment
to have some more interest or more
returns
so for that would be drawing the account
plot and we have set x equal to factor
and now we'll set the palette
so we'll set the parent equal to cool
home
and now we will set line width
that would be equal to 2
and now we'll set the edge color
that would be equal to
black
and we'll use the function PLT dot show
so just run this command and you could
see that we have a sub loader node
subplot better plot and that is a bar
plot
and you could see how many people are
just for returns
that is 25 and we have login period and
who are risking their investment
could see the counter using this count
plot and now moving on we will use
matplotlib and
have another figure
and
here we will be having our plot that is
for purpose like which purpose
which purpose the people are investing
if you could see the purpose here that
is for wealth savings
for which purpose they are investing
wealth creation or just savings for
future
or returns so we'll create a plot here
and for that we'll use
matplotlib
and we will write the command PLT dot
figure
and inside we would set the figure size
that would be equal to 16 comma 8
and after that
would set sns.
Point plot
that is we would be pointing the plots
and set the x parameter as purpose
and Y parameter that would be equal to H
and now we'll set the data
that is equal to DF
and now we will
have the line style as you'll see this
would be a different plot here
and we'll set the line Style with this
style and now we'll set cap size that
would be equal to three
not three that would be 0.3
and after setting the cap size we'll set
the color
and we'll set the color as blue
now we'll write the command PLT Dot
show
and run the command for you guys
so we quote an error that is figure size
and that would be equal to not equal to
equal to
now we'll run this again
and we got Point plot quote and line
Style
okay we have
line style and that would be line styles
yeah we go to our output
that is you can see this graph
this is for just having the purpose and
seeing the IH what would be the median
age for what purpose like who are
investing for wealth creation what is
the median age you can see here for
saying for future purpose you can see
the median age and for returns purpose
you can have the median age
we have used the line Styles here that
is line style is used for each of the
Hue levels that is for each of the
column levels and we've set the cap size
that is the width of the caps on error
bars and that we have set as 0.3
now moving on
we will
create another plot
and that would be our last plot only
so for that we would
be having
the Metro clip Library only and would
set
figure
and here we would be having two subplots
so first we will Define the figure size
that would be fixed size
and that is equal to 18 comma six
and now
we would use the subplot function
PLT dots subplot
and we would Define the parameters for
subplot
and now we'll use C bone sns.
use the count plot function
to have upload and here we will pass you
that would be setting as
gender
and now we'll set the x parameter
that will set as
duration forward duration people are
no but we will have the gender here
so forward duration gender is
each gender is investing
now we'll set the palette
and duration that would mean inverted
Commerce
now inside the palette
that is spell it equal to
where it is you could see the design of
the plot that it would be where it is
and after that we'll set the line width
and that would be equal to
after setting the line width we would
set the edge color
that would be equal to Black
and after that you would set the
title of this subplot
and let's set the title as duration
and now we would have another subplot
for that
subplot
you would write the command PLT dot
subplot and inside would pass the
parameters for this subplot that is 1
comma 2 comma two
and now we would use the
count plot
and inside the count plot will pass hue
and that is equal to
DF
and inside will pass
gender
and that would pass the X parameter that
is
investment monitor
we could see in the
sheet
that is investment monitor
oh sorry like how these genders are
investing they are investing monthly
weekly or daily
so I would see that in
this upload
and
we are passing the investment monitor as
the X parameter
so
we'll pass it investment
underscore monitor
and after the X variable we'll set the
palette
and the pallet would set as seismic
you could see what seismic is when you
will see the upload
and you could use after if you liked it
else you could use another palette and
now we will set the line width and that
would be equal to 2
and after that we would set the edge
color
that would be black for this and now
we'll give the title to this upload and
we will give the title
by using the command PLT dot title and
in the inverted commas we'll write
investment monitoring
and after that we'll write the command
PLT note show
and run the command
and we put an error that is investment
monitor so we'll see invest underscore
monitor it's not investment monitor
so title is okay yeah
invest underscore monitor run it
and you can see uh both the subplots
have been displayed here the first
duration and it's against the counter
and you could see the genders that is
female and male that is how males and
females are investing the investment for
what time period that is one two three
duration for more than five years for
three to five years and for less than
one year and if you see investment
monitoring that how genders are
investing the amount that is how they
are investing monthly what numbers
like you can see that the blue colors
indicate female invest monthly and that
would be in the range
10.02 12.5 that is around 11 and if you
see men they are above 17.5
and same as weekly and daily
and with that we have come to the end of
this session the session was interesting
and informative if you liked it please
let us know in the comment section below
and also do subscribe for more from
Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign